on
que nous
bonsoir premier débat sur le fond à
madrid
israël accepte de discuter de
l'autonomie des territoires occupés le
rapport de force entre direction
gouvernement et syndicats chez renault
le fabuleux duel entre forget sampras il
s'agit de tennis à bercy enfin la mort
du chanteur et pianiste morte schumann
ce sont quelques-uns des titres de cette
édition commentée par françois léotard
le président d'honneur du parti
républicain et ce soir le grand témoin
du 19 mai d'abord la très vive et très
douloureuse émotion à elle dans les
pyrénées-orientales les deux fillettes
disparues depuis le 19 octobre
ingrid et muriel sont mortes leurs corps
a été retrouvé ce soir dans un ravin du
département de l'hérault leurs assassins
présumés a tout avoué
récit isabelle thomas
c'est ici à plus de 100 km den qu'ont
été retrouvés les corps d'ingrid et de
muriel ici que christophe angelo vaines
a conduit les enquêteurs
après avoir nié un moment se souvenir de
l'endroit où il s'était débarrassé des
fillettes
il reste à reconstituer le parcours de
cet homme de 46 ans à partir du 19
octobre date de la disparition des deux
cousines
ce jour là christian van veldhoven
s'arrête à n alors qu'il se rend dans la
région pour y trouver du travail
il est à bord d'une estafette blanche
celle là même qui mettra les enquêteurs
sur sa piste
on sait seulement qu'il prend les
fillettes à son bord pour qu'elle lui
indique une cabine téléphonique
son périple on le sait maintenant le
même jusque vers lodève puis à lourdes
où il tente de se suicider domicilié à
saint dizier
il y est transféré à l'hôpital où les
gendarmes viendront l'interpeller il
avait confié à des amis
j'ai fait une grosse bêtise venger
l'aubaine était parti de saint dizier
après son licenciement d'une entreprise
de menuiserie ses voisins le décrivent
comme un père de famille sans histoire
tous ignoraient qu'il ya un an christian
roudgé lowen avait été condamné pour
attouchements sur deux fillettes dans un
garage souterrain de saint dizier où le
d émotion très vive à elle nous la
population s'efforce depuis ce matin
d'entourer la famille des victimes de
toute son affection mais aussi de sa
colère jeunes savent oro sur place toute
la journée la population est restée
rassemblés devant la mairie
ce matin les illibériens ont tactile un
terrible certitude
les deux cousines ingrid et muriel
inséparables dans la vie sont unis dans
la mort le destin cruel injuste plan de
cette commune paisible dans le désespoir
l'indignation c'est une honte il
faudrait le tuer par peur parce qu'il y
en a trop
le même contrôle difficilement une
situation devenue explosive
je réagis comme la population est le
même qui évidemment voudrait qu'il y ait
dans une justice immédiate qui soit
faite par la population pour une chose
est impossible j'essaie de les calmer
parce qu'il faut laisser faire et quand
même la justice mais mais ce que
évidemment là la population nahd mais
pas c'est que sachant que la peine de
mort maintenant est sublimée et bien
c'est un gars qui dans quelques années
va ressortir leurs comités là les drames
comme celui que nous connaissons nous
parle être diffusée auprès de la
population les parents remercient pour
l'élan de solidarité et le travail des
enquêteurs et des sauveteurs la famille
vende portal appelle la population au
calme par respect pour les deux
fillettes
emmanuelle sanchez jusqu'au bout tiens à
témoigner mais quelque chose à faire en
france c'était justice est elle pas bien
fait si vous voulez séduire je pense à
tous les autres exemples au futile parce
qu'ils auront les mêmes problèmes et je
voudrais pas que ça va sortir ça il
fallait que je le dise 7 j 6 10 il faut
leur faire ça en fin de journée devant
la mairie l'agitation monte encore elle
n'attend dans la piste est ce le retour
des corps et les précisions du juge
d'instruction plots de goze qui
interviendra dans la soirée
et hop de corazones le premier débat sur
le fond à la conférence de paix sur le
proche-orient à madrid où israël a
accepté ce soir de discuter de
l'autonomie des territoires occupés de
cisjordanie et de la bande de gaza
palestiniens et israéliens ont donc fait
un pas en avant aujourd'hui au cours de
leur première réunion bilatérale
la journée étant par ailleurs marquée
par des positions beaucoup plus réservé
des syriens et des libanais qui ont
retardé le moment de leur propre rain ou
filles pisteurs certaines agences
d'information prétendu que la délégation
syrienne ne participerait pas aux
discussions bilatérales c'est
complètement faux c'est une manipulation
destinée à déformer la position arabe
la délégation syrienne sera présent une
déclaration symbolique de l'ambiance à
madrid aujourd'hui une première journée
de discussions bilatérales difficiles
finalement les entretien israélo
libanais devaient commencer à 18h ce
soir les syriens devraient donc suivre à
22 heures après avoir laissé planer le
doute depuis trois jours mais
l'essentiel aujourd'hui ce sont les deux
rencontres ce matin et cet après midi
entre israéliens et palestiniens
rencontrant soit historique de part et
d'autre on parle d' atmosphère positive
on s'est même serré la main résultat ce
soir pour la première fois on aborde le
fond les véritables négociations sont
lancées à l'instant conférence de presse
commune
israéliens et palestiniens acceptent de
discuter de l'autonomie des territoires
occupés les discussions à poursuivre à
une date et en un lieu non encore
préciser le lieu c'est d'ailleurs malgré
tout ce soir le détail qui coince
toujours entre les parties une
hypothèque pour les négociations à venir
malgré cette poignée de main et à ce
propos encore les etats-unis sont prêts
à proposer de nouveaux lieux de réunion
pour la deuxième phase de la conférence
de paix c'est ce qu'annonce ce soir le
secrétaire d'état américain james baker
qui dit également que les états unis
sont prêts rapprocher les points de vue
lors des négociations bilatérales francs
sur les hauteurs on a déjà souligné
l'événement considérable politique
historique culturel qui représentait
donc cette conférence de madrid
j'ai envie de vous diront que de temps
perdu avec ce premier signe
sur le débat de fond entre israéliens et
palestiniens d'une volonté discuté en
fin de l'autonomie des territoires
occupés je crois que le temps est un
facteur essentiel pour arriver à la paix
il a fallu dix ans contre 67 la guerre
des six-jours et 77 la visite de sadate
à jérusalem
il a fallu 13 ans entre cannes david et
notamment le deuxième volet de cas de la
vie qui propose l autonomie enfin la
discussion sur l'autonomie des
territoires occupés et ce soir 22h ou
peut-être on va commencer à en reparler
ou en tout cas dans les jours qui
viennent il faut entendre l'herbe poussé
autour de ces disques discussions mais
moi je suis au ce soir plus
raisonnablement optimiste que je ne
l'étais il ya quelques jours à partir du
moment où le processus bilatéral
s'engage c'est à dire la discussion
entre israël et chacun de ses voisins ce
que je suis un des rares hommes
politiques français à voir proposer ou à
soutenir depuis des années des années et
que hélas les européens ont condamné
depuis maintenant 10 ans et bien un
appartement où ce processus s'engage on
peut être raisonnablement confiant ça
sera très long
ça sera très difficile mais je mets de
la confiance dans ce début de
discussions bilatérales
c'était la bonne formule alors
discussions bilatérales qui s'engage
sous le haut commandement américain on
sent bien la présence de james baker
permanente au cours de ces réunions
bilatérales
un mot sur le strapontin réservée à
l'europe dans cette conférence où marié
j'ai tout à fait fâcheux pour la france
vous savez nous sommes une marque bien
de l'europe oui bien sûr mais je parle
de la france parce que nous sommes la
première puissance méditerranéenne le
liban est un pays méditerranéen la syrie
simple et militaire à l'egypte israël ce
sont des pygmées l'italien et la france
n'est pas présente en tant que tel je
crois qu'il ya quelque chose qui doit
nous interroger très fortement les
américains ne sont pas une puissance
méditerranée les soviétiques n'ont plus
alors avons nous la volonté d'être une
grande puissance méditerranéenne un
avons nous les moyens je crois les
moyens oui et bien sûr avec les autres
pays notamment du sud de l'europe avec
nos amis italiens espagnols
y or nous ne le faisons pas suffisamment
et je souhaite que la france retrouve le
chemin d'une vraie politique
méditerranéenne ce un regret qu'on peut
formuler c'est pas normal que la france
ne soit pas là notamment pour défendre
l'indépendance du liban au pays
aujourd'hui occupés comme l'a été il ya
quelques mois le koweït qui le dit si ce
n'est pas la france et même les autres
européens ne diront pas c'est à la
france aujourd'hui d'être dans cette
discussion à rappeler en permanence
quelques exigences morales ou quelques
exigences territoriales le liban est
aujourd'hui un pays occupé est ce que la
france le dit non elle reçoit monsieur
raoui à paris je crois qu'il faut
absolument que nous demandions au
gouvernement français que sa politique
soit plus claire et sont plus forte
notamment en méditerranée
l'actualité sociale très nourris en
france avec d'abord le rapport de force
entre la direction le gouvernement et
les syndicats chez renault à cléon les
nouvelles tentatives de dialogue ont
échoué et l'on envisage maintenant une
intervention des forces de l'ordre pour
libérer les accès à l'usiné ce qui n'a
pas altéré l'ambiance chez les grévistes
il avait organisé une fête cet après
midi sur place reportage de catherine
leconte cléon sous haute tension la
nouvelle est tombée comme un couperet à
13 heures la direction constate l'échec
des initiatives près ces derniers jours
et refuse toute autre négociation avec
les syndicats pire elle demande aussi
l'application de la décision de justice
du 21 octobre dernier
en clair le déblocage de lusine par les
forces de l'ordre
stupeur incompréhension appréhension
pour les syndicats ce nouveau volte face
et suicidaire dont comprends pas la
position de la direction direction
parlait d'une somme non négligeable donc
il suffisait qu'elle avance un petit peu
est ce que vous avez peur aujourd'hui de
ce qui pourrait se passer
écoutez je crois que la cgt on n'a pas
peur mais enfin on pense que ce serait
une grave erreur de faire intervenir les
forces de l'ordre maintenant ce matin
pourtant tout était encore possible
martine aubry appelait au dialogue et
un doute à espérer d'une rencontre avec
la direction cet après midi c'est en
famille que les grévistes en état de
choc tentait d'oublier ce climat glacial
un dernier espoir les salariés prêts à
négocier en ont appelé ce soir au
ministre du travail
il demande une réunion tripartite ou
direction syndicats du ministère
pourrait enfin trouver la solution de ce
conflit
ce soir lusine connaîtra sa 19e ni des
blocus françois martine aubry a raison
s'est montré ferme sur ce dossier je le
crois je crois en tout cas qu'on ne peut
pas négocier tant qu'une décision de
justice n'est pas appliquée dans cette
affaire il ya une justice qui est
bafouée la décision était prise et le
prévoyait des mesures sur l' usine on
empêche les travailleurs qui le veulent
de travailler il faut que la justice se
respecter l'un comme ailleurs pourquoi
il ya des endroit en france où la
justice mme ne peut pas s'appliquer un
juge c'est un juge partout et il
s'applique il est jeune il juge
il décide sur une un conflit de ce genre
comme ailleurs donc les forces de
l'ordre doivent intervenir demain
arrêtions décision juste c'est pas une
décision de l'état c'est une décision de
la justice lorsqu on comprendra que la
justice
normalement est indépendante de l'état
ou devraient l'être on aura fait un
grand pas en avant en france encore les
manifestations d'agriculteurs hier soir
agen dans le lot et garonne environ 200
manifestants se sont rassemblés vers 23
heures avant de se diriger vers la
préfecture dont ils ont soudé la grille
d'entrée
ils ont également répandu quelques
milliers de litres de lisier bombardé
l'édifice avec des tomates des oeufs et
divers projectiles
ils ont mis le feu à des pneus et à de
la paille ensuite avant de se disperser
vers zéro heure trente
autre dossier social très sensible celui
de la santé les négociations entre le
gouvernement et les personnels soignants
sont toujours dans l'impasse les
manifestations de la semaine sont
nombreuses elles sont détaillées par
agnès molinier les infirmières
reprennent le sentier de la guerre
opération hôpitaux mort mardi à l'appel
des syndicats course marathon mercredi
et manifestations jeudi à l'appel de la
coordination pendant trois jours elles
vont faire parler d'elle motif peser de
tout leur poids sur des négociations qui
devraient reprendre dans les jours qui
viennent
interrompu le 29 octobre elle portait
sur des phrases sont postés
l'attribution de primes
aucun accord n'a pu être conclu le
ministre revoit sa copie
plus généralement c'est l'hôpital dans
son ensemble qui va sortir de sa réserve
jeudi les personnels d'île de france
appellent à manifester le jour où les
assistants sociaux ont choisi de faire
une nouvelle action si le malade est
grand dans le secteur public
le mécontentement s'exprime aussi dans
le privé mardi sera journée d'action
pour l'ensemble des professionnels de la
santé
ils protestent contre la politique du
gouvernement pour maîtriser les dépenses
de l'assurance maladie
pour eux il s'agit d'une mamie de l'état
conduisant au rationnement des soins
leur action de mardi servira de première
mobilisation en vue de la grande
manifestation prévue le 17 novembre
il espère 500 mille participants déjà le
11 juin dernier ils étaient plus de
cinquante mille dans les rues de paris
un mot concernant la médecine libérale
et revendications des uns et des autres
il faut bien maîtriser quand même le
déficit de la sécurité sociale on ne
peut pas en permanence contester la
gestion des uns ou des autres et les
trous profonds et de l'autre réclamèrent
en permanence un soutien financier plus
important
non bien entendu nul a les infirmières
ont raison je crois qu'il faut que
l'opinion publique les soutiennent parce
que il y à une crise qui est à la fois
une crise de rémunération mais ce n'est
pas la seule à ce niveau de formation à
cette utilité sociale correspond des
salaires qui sont médiocres et une crise
aussi de reconnaissance et de comment
dire des conditions de travail et ça je
crois que devant il travaille je suis
dit ce président-là l'hôpital je dois
dire que je mesure tous les jours ce que
sont les conditions de travail des
infirmiers et des infirmières crois
qu'il faut que nous fassions un effort
et ça passe par une rupture de la grille
cette affreuse grille de la fonction
publique qui fait que si vous augmentez
les infirmières lendemain vous avez les
instituteurs le surlendemain
les autres enseignants après les acteurs
etc
et ça c'est un système bloqué il faut le
courage de casser ce système bloqué et
d'améliorer les conditions de ceux qui
sont en situation productivité sociale
ce qui est le cas des infirmiers alors
d'accord pour les infirmières je reviens
à ma question qu'y toucher davantage de
la médecine libérale
on ne peut pas vis-à-vis la m numéral
sacha nouilles et le cabinet d'affaires
réseau maîtriser les dépenses ça suppose
une plus grande responsabilisation des
citoyens eux mêmes
on ne peut pas effectivement continuer à
augmenter les dépenses de santé plus que
la richesse nationale ce qui se fait
depuis des années et des années
ça veut dire que chacun accepte de
prendre en charge lui-même dans sa
famille un peu davantage de ces
dépenses-là à son compte et non pas en
les reportant a défini mans sur un
système social collectif dans lequel
personne n'est responsable
il sait qu'il aura le courage de le dire
et de le faire car ce qui concerne les
médecins qui défileront dans la rue vous
en raison tant celui d'hier il ya une
dégradation extraordinaire de l'ue du
métier de médecin qui n'est pas un
métier comme les autres
je crois qu'ils ont raison messieurs
brocard avait il faut dire des choses
aussi on parle d'argent monsieur rocard
les 300 milliards de recettes fiscales
en caisse quand il a engagé son mandat
en 1988 il fallait que les français le
sachent 300 milliards de recettes
fiscales supplémentaires bien début de
mandat début de septennat soutien
majoritaire au parlement
il pouvait faire ce qu'ils voulaient
politique maintenant michel poniatowski
s'exprime à nouveau mais cette fois sur
une éventuelle alliance avec le front
national le sénateur plr estime évident
que des discussions et des arrangements
interviendront avec le front national
une fois connu le résultat des
prochaines élections régionales il
demande donc à l'udf de ne pas fermer
les portes entretien accordé vous le
voyez au journal du dimanche
et puis ce soir agitée de l'a5 monsieur
peut négocier a ajouté j'attends que
monsieur le pen le dise qu'il est
antisémite et raciste pour ne pas faire
alliance avec lui françois léotard vous
avez fait connaître publiquement dans
les colonnes du monde
la fermeté de vos sentiments à propos de
l'invasion des immigrés ce n'était même
pas à propos de l'occupation
vous condamnez tout accord avec le front
national et vous l'avez déjà exprimé
publiquement
répondez-moi clairement qu est-ce qui
réunit aujourd'hui françois léotard et
michel poniatowski au sein de la même
famille politique
vous me permettez une parabole parce que
ça va être la vraie réponse à ce que
vous dites monsieur poniatowski et je
regrette ces déclarations et dans la
situation d'un berger qui dit j'ai deux
cent cinq bêtes dont j'en ai plus que
celui d'à côté qu'un à 200 il oublie de
dire qu'il ya 200 moutons et saint cloud
c'est ça son troupeau et quand on ne
mélange pas on additionne pas à ces
choses là ça n'est pas vrai c'est une
fausse addition il ne prend pas en
compte cette réalité affreuse depuis
maintenant 10
donc monsieur le pen s'appuie sur
monsieur mitterrand et que monsieur
mitterrand s'appuie sur monsieur le pen
le ps aujourd'hui ne pourrait pas
exister dans la situation dans laquelle
ils s il y avait pas le pen comme
repoussoir
le front national n'existerait pas s'il
ne s'appuyait pas sur le désordre causé
par le parti socialiste
alors on va pas dire que la france est
réduite à cela quand même il ya entre
les deux une place immense pour des
républicains sincères et de bonne
volonté et ses 7 places qu'on essaye de
aujourd'hui de d'étouffer ou de
supprimer vous appuierez le cds la
semaine prochaine au congrès l'udf pour
demander l'exclusion du château
la décision a déjà été prise l'article 7
des statuts du ps moi je me considère
comme un adhérent direct de l'udf et
donc je respecte les statuts qu'on ne
revienne pas toutes les cinq minutes
revenir sur ce que nous avons déjà
décidé qu'ils ont actuellement la
discipline républicaine de la droite
française qu'on regarde qui le fait
c'est pas moi moi je respecte les
statuts que nous nous sommes donnés
alors je crois qu'il faut maintenant
raison garder et que l'on sache bien que
le champignon le pen il pousse sur des
terrains décomposer alors qu'on ne
vienne pas en rajouter alors d'autres
petites questions liées à l'actualité
politique du jour françois bayrou a
demandé aujourd'hui il était l'invité de
rmc le départ de françois mitterrand où
on va pas faire un putsch
bien sûr je le souhaite tout le groupe
ii souhaite maintenant vous avez les
nombreux elle souhaitait en france mais
on va pas faire un putsch et je crois
que dans les périodes difficiles comme
celle que nous traversons rappelons
encore le droit
il est là pour sept ans et la
constitution des français que la
constitution à l'épaule quand elle nous
arranger mauvaise il faudrait il faut
réformer les institutions
oui oui il faut redonner du pouvoir aux
parlements la sphère du sens pour ne
prendre que cet exemple parmi beaucoup
d'autres où les crises sociale que nous
traversons dans un régime normalement
démocratique elle aboutissait la
sanction sur le gouvernement tenir au
départ du gouvernement
ce que souhaite beaucoup de français or
là le ces mécanismes ne fonctionne plus
c'est à dire les gens sont en colère ils
sont dans la rue il ya des scandales et
ça ne change rien
le gouvernement reste le même j'allais
dire a défini mais il faut des
institutions qui permet de mettre en
cause le gouvernement et donc de le
renverser
alors qu'on ne nous dise pas c'est la
quatrième république parce que ça c'est
la démocratie
oui mais c'est la démocratie aussi et la
quatrième au public ne mérite pas cet
excès d'indignité
et je crois qu'il faut que nous
revenions par des procédures toutes deux
modifications modestes mais progressive
de la constitution
un esprit républicain et démocratique
nous ne sommes plus tout à fait dans cet
esprit là un dernier mot votre avis sur
la réforme du mode de scrutin à pau de
proportionnelle ou pas je vais vous dire
une chose simple quel qu'il soit mais
qu'on ne change plus qu'en 25 ans la
pire des choses c'est de changer à
chaque élection alors quel qu'il soit
devenu faiblesse pour le majoritaire
uninominal à un tour système britannique
mais quel qu'il soit mais alors que l'on
change puis qu'on le mette dans la
constitution et que pendant 30 ans les
français se disent on va pas essayer de
voler nos voix à la veille d'une
élection en changeant le mode de scrutin
la mort aujourd'hui à londres du
chanteur et pianiste maurice schumann à
l'âge de 53 ans personnage un peu
atypique du showbiz il avait surtout
occupé la tête des hit parades dans les
années 70 portraits tristan faire alors
nous avons bien sûr mortimer qui est
avec nous pour la deuxième journée morte
schuman est apparu sur la scène
française dans les années 70 il avait
pourtant alors déjà derrière lui une
sacrée carrière de compositeur avec
notamment une vingtaine de titres écrits
jeu pour elvis presley
d'origine polonaise née à new york
mortimer des coûts la chanson française
à travers jacques brel pour qu'ils
éprouvaient une immense admiration
il s'installe alors à paris le lac
majeur soro papa tango charlie
deviennent alors d'énormes tubes dans
notre pays
cette gloire soudaine n'étonnera
d'ailleurs au premier chef
heureusement son physique de nounours
cacher un véritable épicurien amateur de
plaisir et de sensations
installé à londres depuis 1987 il y est
mort hier à l'âge de 53 ans des suites
d'une longue maladie
la terre
d
fais danser
tu peux
camus
les sports maintenant est d'abord bien
sûr le tennis la superbe victoire de guy
forget cette après midi en finale de
l'open de paris bercy
il a battu pete sampras en cinq sets
match exceptionnel et très disputé il
est balèze un match tendu entre deux des
plus grands serveurs du circuit
international match d'attentes pour guy
forget crispé qui laisse l'initiative du
filet à son adversaire
le marseillais remporte le premier set
après une heure de jeu et un jeu décisif
très acharné 7 6 cette rencontre
constitue en fait la belle entre deux
géants qui pensent déjà à la coupe davis
sampras accélère le jeu semble prendre
l'ascendant dans le deuxième set qu'il
remporte 6 4 dans la troisième manche
chaque joueur perd tour à tour son
service sampras n'est pas dans un grand
jour il alterne coup de génie et fautes
directes forgé en profite en fait tout
va se jouer dans le neuvième jeu de la
dernière manche
sampras crack forget triomphe après
trois heures et 44 minutes de match
pression qui avait presque quinze mille
copains à là quand même
ouais c'est vrai que vont les conditions
c'est chez pas s'y retrouver c'est un
jour dans ma vie de moi je serai content
d'avoir fait une fois un guy forget
lucide conscient de l'importance qu'a
joué le public mais aussi du fait qu'il
n'était pas à son meilleur niveau
plusieurs fois j'étais presque pas deux
doigts de décrocher mais je ne pouvais
que capituler sur quelques sur plein des
changes peut dominer complètement et
j'ai vraiment l'impression des fois
d'être un petit un petit garçon que le
professeur vient qu'il mettait des
espèces de deux bombes à droite et à
gauche à plat mais bon moi je me
bagarrais comme je pouvais guy forget
conforte ce soir le gain avec un sixième
tournoi de sa place en équipe de france
on vous dira françois léotard c'est un
match marathon
je crois qu'en sport on voit aurait
souvent le corps est là il faut penser à
ce cas dans la tête j'ai on gagne avec
la tête et ce qui est formidable c'est
forget il le dit c'est qu'il ya eu cette
opiniâtreté cette résistance de la tête
en fait le corse on s'entraîne la tête
c'est plus compliqué
formule 1 parodie aide au grand prix ce
matin sur le circuit d'adélaïde en
australie 30 minutes de course à ayrton
senna finalement déclaré vainqueur
après une partie d'autos tamponneuses
provoqués par les intempéries
récit de ce qui a failli être une course
didier chaumont dernière épreuve de tous
les dangers la mauvaise une horde ayrton
senna qui réclament l'arrêt immédiat des
hostilités
ce sera chose faite au 16ème tour des
pluies diluviennes sur ce circuit
d'adélaïde rend de la piste extrêmement
dangereuse
il n'en fallait pas plus pour déclencher
la colère des pilotes de glissades en
tête à queue d'accrochages en figures
imposées la grogne après 25 minutes de
course fusent de toutes parts les
pilotes d'une même voix clame nous
n'aurions jamais dû accepter de prendre
le départ
mais voilà des teams de pouvoir de dire
non il y avait peut-être que le
brésilien ayrton senna pour prendre
cette décision
comme a eu le courage de le faire prost
en 89 dans les mêmes conditions
inconscience donc des organisateurs une
fois de plus les intérêts financiers ont
prévalu sur la sécurité des pilotes
ayrton senna remporte ce grand prix
devant mansell après arrêt de la course
le couronnement pour senna et un titre
mondial des constructeurs pour l'écurie
mclaren honda françois houtart tel
friandises ou juste trop saillants je
pense qu'on aurait dû interdire ça au
fond ne pas la faire cette course on met
en jeu la vie des gens des pilotes et
pourquoi parce que j'imagine que
beaucoup d'argent derrière c'est pas
très bien merci d'avoir été le grand
témoin du 19/20 ce soir instant météo
complète de fabienne amiach suivi de
béni les puis à 20h30
la grande finale de questions pour un
champion animé par julien lepers soir 3
et à 22h15 dans la page cinéma avec
henry chapier je recevrai le comédien
pierre arditi par c10 il a un très bon
l'unique soirée